let's bring in Rich Eisen rich let's
start with the important question how do
you pronounce Jacksonville's nickname I
like that I like that good yeah there
was it didn't sound fake at all mmm
I'm a Jaguar I'm a Jaguar I'm not a
Jaguar that jumps out at me whatever
hear people say Jaguar I don't
understand that it's j AG jag you are
that's it where's the wire I don't know
where's the W where the I but then you
have the English pronunciation I'd you
were thank you yeah that's an AB you
were three syllables yeah I don't get
Jaguar well the British don't pronounce
the second a it's Jaguar Owen its owner
right I think I mean I don't know well
when they move to London I just want to
make sure I know how the locals are
gonna pronounce Dan as you know and when
they do that we as American sports
broadcasters are mandated to say they
play across the pond huh okay you know
right now the Australian Open is going
on down under I mean that's the way
that's the way we must just do our job
he would always do that on SportsCenter
when when it was never just the
Australian Open it's let's go down under
the Australian Open let's go across the
pond all right here's our poll question
McLovin ask it for Rich Eisen with the
playoffs be more or less interesting if
Tom Brady got injured come on man how
about the same how about the same it's
it's the same what do you mean more or
less interesting because he him him him
playing makes it less interesting
because we're all assuming they're gonna
kick the Jaguars ass because he's in
there I don't know I would go the same
but you know but then again maybe that's
because of what I do for a living I'm I
think it would be just as there would be
awful if Brady's not out there you want
to see him at age 40 playing in a in a
AFC Championship game when everybody
thinks that maybe this is the time where
a young team like Jacksonville
can do in essence what atlanta did in
the first half of the Super Bowl last
year which is make him look old it's
entirely possible that that happens on
on Sunday and that it's entirely
possible that Brady just torches him and
gets back to another Super Bowl and has
an opportunity to win a second in a row
as a 40 year old and then win that thing
and then want to come back so he can be
the first to win three in a row as a 41
year old
I don't I don't buy into whatever I
think you know the fact that they're
nine-point favorites for entertainment
purposes only if he wasn't playing
they'd be a two-point favorite and would
we be more curious about how this would
play out because you don't have Brady
there
I want Brady there on Super Bowl Sunday
win or lose it's better but I we were
just thinking you know this this game
against Jacksonville if he wasn't there
I think it would be a whole lot more
interesting for people I mean wouldn't
you want to see no to me it would be
less interesting who wants to watch
Brian Hoyer in a big spot I mean we just
went through a whole season where JJ
Watt Odell Beckham Aaron Rodgers deshaun
Watson I mean I could go on and on and
on of the bold-faced names that got hurt
and we had a and we and we watched
people but well I guess in a way it led
to an ascension of somebody like Case
Keenum wouldn't you rather would it be
more it would it be more interesting if
Carson Wentz was playing this game this
weekend with all due respect to Nick
Foles yes I mean so and Plus to me you
know you look at Jacksonville you see
someone like Jalen Ramsay reminds me of
the of the you know why you mad yeah
Richard Sherman when they beat Brady in
their building and we're really brash
and we're beginning to serve notice on
the league that they're for real and
this could be their moment
I mean it's entirely possible that that
happens with Leonard fournette running
down their throat and and and the
defense keeping things you know up the
middle of the field clogged enough that
Brady is forced to go outside at boy way
and Ramsey you know this is just a
hypothetical rich we're not rooting
Hyman I I know it's this is for
entertainment purposes
a little bit of understand and so I
don't know Danny I'm just getting ready
I'm getting ready for my show to have
takes that's what I'm trying to do I'm
working my way up for my show in about
50 minutes to have my takes okay a
serious question yes sir when you
realize what the landscape is in TV and
having hot takes and these shows that
are popular does it make did it make you
has it made you reconsider how you say
something or having a hot take not being
serious that don't you are to put a
statement out there now that maybe
that's not what we were accustomed to
doing certainly when we worked at ESPN
but this is the norm now of you must
have a hot take I know that and it you
know for me to just even opinionate and
the first year of doing this show was
difficult honestly I mean after being of
an essential traffic cop for much of my
career to come out and and have a show
that it's it's an opinion of mine was
just difficult to even you know under
conjure up even if it was legit and I've
never had a take on the air that's not
legit I'll be honest I take that cue
from you Dan having watched and listened
to your show for as long as it's been on
the air for real and I think you can
have an opinion never you never
manufacture no no I don't want to and
it's it's either either you you you know
I I don't have a problem saying when
somebody calls into the show or when
something happens to say you know what
both sides are right and I you know it
was so easy for me over the last two
days to say Mike Tomlin should be out it
was egregious what happened on Sunday
with play calling in that onside kick
and yeah you know whatever's going on
out there with the minority owners that
want him out and they're gonna try and
lobby for with Art Rooney and Steeler
fans were pissed off but have been so
easy for me to go Tomlin it's time but
no I went the other way saying he's
terrific and he would be on the street
for five seconds it would have been him
on the street would have been like the
football on the
to start an XFL game the the Titans and
the Lions and the Cardinals and maybe
even the Giants would have jumped at him
and so to me I don't mind having a take
that his nuance and maybe something
that's positive to be honest with you
talking to Rich Eisen NFL Network host
and the host of the Rich Eisen show and
DIRECTV's audience Network explain this
to me given this dealer situation that
Ben Roethlisberger said that he can't
audible to a quarterback so now he can
audible to a fake spike but not a
quarterback sneak it's crazy that
doesn't pass the smell test here in no
no it does not it does not certainly you
know there should be some form of Omaha
or dilly dilly to change into that and I
that did not pass the smell test at all
and when I heard that all I thought to
myself is he wants somebody out of there
and yes and I think he succeeded you
know I obviously don't think he's the
only voice of displeasure involving the
offense it can't be and that's another
reason why Mike Collins done an
incredible job I mean Ben Roethlisberger
we have a quarterback saying stuff like
that I don't hear any other quarterback
in the league sharing personal thoughts
and dirty laundry on things like play
calls and final moments of crucial games
like the one against the Patriots you
don't see running backs holding out too
much you don't see wide receivers
posting videos live on Facebook from the
locker room you don't see all time great
pass rushers demanding more snaps and
then once he leaves have a whole big
argument going back and forth between
veterans of the team and obviously you
don't see coaches having to deal with
players suddenly being paralyzed like
Tomlin has this year and that's just a
handful of situations we know about the
guys terrific and they're always winning
and they're always Super Bowl contenders
so that said though what Penn said was
was eyebrow-raising to say the least
yeah I don't get that it's it's like is
does he want to play don't know if I'm
gonna play and and all of a sudden you
know the fake spike and then I can't
audible to a quarterback sneak and okay
it just wait way too much drama the
Steelers and you know III always say
they lead the league in drama it's they
can't leave the drama behind after they
create it whereas the Patriots can leave
it behind given what happened prior to
their first playoff game granted it's
Tennessee but there's no remnants of
that article by ESPN right now now it
may rear its ugly head in the offseason
but the Patriots look at it and then
examine and then they move on whereas
the the Steelers they drag it with them
and that that's that's the difference
between these two franchises that's
where the Patriots are so unique the
only comparison I can make and you tell
me if if you think of somebody else in
sports that I've been around or covered
now let's just remove the politics and
the Breitbart and all that stuff from it
but Curt Schilling was very similar to
that when I covered the World Series
between the Diamondbacks and the Yankees
one of the players on the Arizona
Toba the nickname they had for him was
Web MD because he constantly would talk
about what hurt him and Ben is kind of
like that too you know where things are
discussed about injuries and
play-calling
but like Schilling you know Ben's a
champion when it all came down to it
getting in between the lines and it's
probably not easy to coach let's be
honest yeah but now Ben's got his
quarterback coach as his as is OC and
this is a guy who by all accounts coming
out of Pittsburgh was the buffer between
him and Haley for many years so maybe
this is actually something that will
work out for him and and and levy on
bail and what have you moving forward
maybe that's it thank you for joining us
rich as always yeah the you bet say hi
to the Schwab please whoo
I will the Rich Eisen show coming up at
noon Eastern yes and you'd please do me
this favor because as you know we
discussed this a few weeks ago what
would be his favorite nickname for Adam
feeling hooked on a feeling hooked on a
feeling I don't know feeling alright
would be good one but I just want to
know just off the top of his okay
would be alright maybe I'll just ask him
that question then that's it I'll say
Chris thank you thanks for joining us
thank you ready for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]